well congratulations you guys you're
expecting your first baby together
kind of walk me through the moment you
found out and also how you're doing
because ashley you and i just kind of
talked and it's been a little hard
yeah you know what i have gotten so much
feedback over the past like 72 hours
from people
on instagram and it's so crazy how many
people are so sick
like honestly when i'm reading like
comparing my experience to all these
others
i'm like middle range you know like i
throw up
not every single day some days are
really bad but some days are pretty bad
i feel bad but some days i don't throw
up at all and like there are some women
that are messaging me
about like just it'd be non-stop
and i'm like wow like i guess i'm kind
of like in a sense lucky even though i
don't like in my stomach feel it right
now but
yeah as a guy i didn't know anything
either i just knew morning sickness so i
thought oh
when you're pregnant early on you get
sick in the morning and then you're fine
in the afternoon at night and that is
not the case i have no idea who came
with morning sickness
but that turn needs to go away because
poor ash has been throwing up constantly
and constantly nauseous
we're super blessed and grateful that we
are pregnant because we know a lot of
people struggle out there and we were
trying for about seven months
so i mean i guess i shouldn't say that
i'm not the one going through the
sickness right now so yeah our thing now
is like
we are not pregnant don't know where
that expression we're pregnant came from
because the girl is pregnant
i'm just having a kid along with yeah
it's like we're having a child
yeah but you are the one that's pregnant
yes but when we found out
it was a month that we didn't think we
were going to be pregnant no
she was so good at keeping track of
ovulation and scheduling everything and
it was the one month that
everything was a little off i was just
off like my schedule was off
so and this was after seven months so we
thought well it's definitely not
happening this month
and it happened this month yeah but my
business is so
far like more than just pre-period sore
so
i was like all right i'm gonna take a
test it's gonna be negative so i'm not
even gonna tell him that way to take a
test but then
when like i moseyed along and looked at
the results
it was like a faint line spain second
line and i was like
that's silly i told him and then he
didn't believe it for a long time
he didn't even believe it after like
multiple positive tests
oh yeah that's fair i'm not getting my
hopes up so you guys tried for seven
months
was there a point that you felt like is
this in the cards for us
no actually my age my doctor was like
you go for a year
before you go for a year okay i was
gonna get my
sperm tested i don't know i don't know
how else to phrase it i think it was
like frustrating because you're like oh
my god we're doing everything right like
how could this not be happening
but i do i wasn't like at the real
concern point i was like at the like
when i get my period i get a little
disappointed point
but i wasn't really concerned but we did
want to do the sperm analysis just
because
one out of every three couples who
struggle with infertility it's the guy
who has the issue so you can rule that
out really quickly
with just a completely non-invasive
super simple test
and well the month that he was going to
go and do that
we thought that was right i know you
hear so many different stories like this
couple's been trying for five years to
get pregnant and then
these you know other couple first try
and it was like okay we're pregnant
it's it's insane i am sorry that you're
sick jared how has it been we saw on
your on the instagram
you there with ashley throwing up for
you to sort of
watch her go through this and support
her through this
it's been tough i i feel terrible
because uh
you know it's our kid and yet i'm not
any different
i don't feel sick you know so my daily
life hasn't really changed all that much
so i'm just trying to be here for
ashley as as much as possible he feels
like kind of helpless which is sweet
because like would obviously i'll be
sick and he's like what can i do to help
him like literally like nothing like he
runs errands to me which is
like yeah i get slurpees i get chocolate
cake i fulfill the cravings other than
that it's like this cycle of like hey
you need crackers
you want some plain pasta ginger
for the 17th time today oh what what are
you craving ashley chocolate cake what
else
chocolate chip pancakes are the one
thing that i haven't thrown up
like the one thing that i eat constantly
that i don't throw up so i love my
chocolate chip pancakes
you guys aren't gonna find out the sex
this week but i know that your
grandmother gave you some advice
about what she thinks the sex could be
my grandmother said if i'm pregnant
with a boy i'll get prettier especially
for my second trimester
and then if i am with a girl i'll get
uglier because the girl sucks your
beauty
and i'm okay with the girl sucking my
beauty because i want a girl
we find out yeah on wednesday we don't
really know what we're gonna do like we
haven't even talked about this like i
think that we'll have them give us the
envelope and then we'll decide from
there
i don't want to like be in the
ultrasound room and find out i don't
think
it's really up to ash i mean she's been
getting the brunt of this so whatever
she wants i'm good with it
i think both of us think it's a boy i've
always thought it was a boy just
you thought it was a boy before we got
pregnant he's been saying we're gonna
have our first is gonna be a boy
and i've had a gut feeling about that
too i think it's just because i want a
girl so bad that like i know it'll
probably end up being a boy
yeah and i'm in different because i want
a boy and i want a girl so
okay all right tom brady jersey early on
yeah
have you guys picked out names for if
it's a boy or a girl yet have you talked
about that if it's a boy we have a name
picked out
i've had this name picked out since i
was like 20. and
jared really liked it i had another name
for a girl that i had picked out but he
didn't like that one
but it's okay because i'm far more
attached to the boy name so
yeah i the name that she picked out i
love for a boy and we actually just
figured out
the middle name as well so we have our
if it is a boy we have the first animal
name all set
and we love movies and there's a little
nod to
a couple films uh in the name which is
ridiculous but also like so meaningful
to us and it's a great name and we love
it
and um nobody would know except for us
you know
i love that who is the first person in
bachelor nation that you guys
told but i told ben mainly because ben
and i do the podcast every week together
and like i just wasn't feeling good and
i just wanted him to know like if that
was kind of like
seeming a little bit less energetic than
usual there was a reason behind it
yeah i think ben was probably the first
one to know in bachelor we face time
with tanner and jade and we told them
which was very exciting because we're
very close to them we called dick
and it was the most nick thing of all
time because first of all he was outside
with his shirt off and i was like okay
this is perfect
and then he answered the phone he's like
you guys are pregnant aren't you it was
like
yeah oh yeah he's like why else would
you face tommy right now it was nine in
the morning la time
like i mean we were like together with
our faces like this i know and it was so
funny so we talked about ashley being
pregnant for about 90 seconds and then
we
we started talking about this tick-tock
most nick thing of all time i love it
who of you guys
cried the most when you found out or did
you
hear that like we didn't really cry well
i was talking about this and i've talked
about it with a lot of
my friends who are fathers and there's
almost a little guilt because i don't
feel that connected
with the baby yet the only time i did
feel truly really connected was when we
went for the first doctor's appointment
we saw the ultrasound and even though
you know it's the size of
an ant right now in a sack the size of a
blueberry
like i've only ever seen that in movies
you know putting the gel on her stomach
and
moving the ultrasound be like oh that's
that's the baby right there and there's
a little heartbeat and i was like oh wow
this is very real
seeing my sister cry and like my mom
like it's
watching people cry for us that made me
more emotional
and just like looking at the positives
and i had a moment with my dad my dad is
truly my hero like he's the ultimate
family guy i've never met a human being
who loves his family more than my dad
loves
you know me my sister and my mom and we
had like a quick
10-second moment where he was just like
you know you're gonna be
he's like i know the man you are and
you're gonna be a great dad
and i said thanks dad
what will it be like when you do have
your little one
to return to paradise will that feel
full circle for you guys you're like
emotional
that'll be very full circle because i
know it's ridiculous for people to think
but that beach down in paradise
it's very significant it's where we
first met we got engaged
it's where we went through a lot of ups
and downs i think we grew a lot
uh together and separately on that beach
the idea of going back to it
with our it child insane
um yesterday incredible yesterday i was
telling jared
i was like reminiscing on this time
where we weren't together
and i threw up hungover in his car and
i'm like i can't believe that i was like
so embarrassed throwing up
in your car like knowing you for six
months and now i throw up with you in
the car all the time because i'm
pregnant with your
child like it's so weird no shame just
grab the plastic bag and be like i gotta
throw up
all right go do what you need do we need
to do